Damn, I'm freezing.
Oh, that's warm.
Oh, the hero's back!
Heard you fired off your gun!
-Here comes the hotshot!
-Hey!
-I don't want to hear it.
-You took equipment again.
-Coming back from a triathlon?
-I won!
You're the laughing stock of the station.
--doesn't mean it's okay!
You're not supposed to fire your gun
without clearance.
That's enough already.
Why are you on my case--?
-What I'm saying is--
-I can't hear you because of the water.
And the GPS round you fired
-is something I developed.
-Oh, James.
-People will think I had a part in it.
-You got to a sauna?
It worked out, so what's the problem?
No, it didn't.
-I'm telling you this for your own sake.
-Keep it to yourself.
What are you doing after this?
I'm going to get my things and go home
before he finds me.
Before he finds you? What are you--?
Welcome back.
You should've left before he found you.
When asked about the bribery allegations
made against LIVE Corporation,
the company's chairman, Steven Martland,
stated that the reports are baseless--
Did you not know?
You're not supposed to hurt
material witnesses.
I think you saw
that I had no other choice--
Why did you fire your gun
without permission?
I always tell you not to jump the gun.
-But I had no choice in that situation--
-Also...
You had a choice when you took equipment
from the station without the paperwork.
-James, how many years have you been here?
-Seven years.
Yes, it will be eight years.
You should know what kind of organization
we're running here by now.
This is a police organization
responsible for
maintaining peace and order in society.
And we are the bureau in charge
of the dangerous cases
-which require careful countermeasures.
-Which require careful countermeasures.
That is our job at the SSC.
Everyone here recognizes your abilities.
Your clearance rate is off the charts.
It brings me pride as a fellow SSC member.
-Thank you, sir.
-However!
Reckless actions puts others in danger.
I called you in here because I'd like you
to do something about that.
The SSC is an organization in which
you are an individual member.
Yes, sir...
Here's the paperwork.
You get to fill it out.